Disney has just dropped the official
Aladdin movie trailer and fans are
bubbling with excitement the 2019
live-action remake has done the original
justice by mimicking some key moments
from its trailer we've spotted some
major differences and startling
similarities between the two versions
we're about to dissect the trailer to
the T so watch until the end to find out
why the remake is receiving mixed
reviews back in 1992 kids and parents
alike sat around their television sets
to view the official Aladdin trailer and
Disney didn't disappoint flash-forward
to 2019 and fans are wondering if Disney
will live up to their reputation and by
the looks of it they will the official
trailer for the live-action remake is
jam-packed with bright colors awesome
effects and familiar songs so what's not
to like the trailer opens up with a
chase and we see the musical number one
jump ahead flash across the screen
Aladdin is being chased through the
streets of Agrabah we catch a glimpse of
the adorable Abu as he lands on Aladdin
shoulder and then it happens
Aladdin sees jasmine for the very first
time the trailers intro ends with a love
at first sight moment which is a very
different opener than the one Disney
used in 1992 the authentic trailer
starts off with the desert Sun and a
lone traveler riding on Camelback we
then come face-to-face with the opening
to the Cave of Wonders and watch as
Aladdin happens upon the lamp so much
happens within the first few seconds of
the trailer and the events promised an
epic journey
the trailers intro finishes with Genie
making his grand appearance we're not
saying that one trailer is better than
the other but from the looks of it
Disney has chosen to pursue a more
romantic angle for their live-action
remake after all it is targeting an
older audience this time around the 1992
trailer goes on to show Aladdin wishing
to become a prince he's then seen
parading through the streets of Agrabah
before things take a turn for the worse
Jafar as evil face makes its first
appearance and he's furious over the
fact that Aladdin has the lamp Jafar
psychic Iago comes sweeping in as
Aladdin flees on his magic carpet at
this point we're already halfway through
the trailer and jasmine
has yet to make her grand debut this is
very different from the 2019 trailer
which goes on to highlight the princess
once again the second part of the new
trailer starts off with who we can only
assume is too far
he's creepily walking down a demo
hallway with his snake staff in hand the
scene changes and were reunited with
Aladdin who is traveling through the
desert on Camelback with three other
riders finally the Cave of Wonders and
the magic lab are introduced into the
plot and we see a lot and rub the lamp
and release genie from its Fortress of
Solitude some fans are angry that actor
Will Smith is playing the very blue and
very CGI'd genie but let's face it after
watching Robin Williams performance in
the original fans won't be happy with
whatever actor tries to fill his shoes
so let's give Will Smith a fighting
chance we mean as The Fresh Prince ever
let us down before the live-action
trailer goes on to show Aladdin and
Genie becoming quick friends genie turns
the street rat into Prince Ali and helps
him court Prince Jasmine a few funny
jokes are exchanged and genies classic
you ain't never had a friend like me
number dances across the screen Disney
really went all out in the special
effects Department the live-action
remake looks incredible the trailer then
highlights Aladdin in Jasmine's magic
carpet bride while diving into some
pretty hectic fighting scenes fireworks
a frozen landscape and a giant new Yago
sum up the trailer's events and we have
to admit the movie looks pretty darn
good now let's take a look at how the
1992 trailer ended before spotting out
some major differences between the films
we have to give it to them Disney really
stayed true to the originals trailer in
fact they pretty much end on the same
note the 1992 trailer finally introduces
Princess Jasmine in second half we see
her aboard Aladdin's magic carpet and
sewer through Sky's freedom at last a
whole new world carries the rest of the
trailer as we see our heroes go up
against their foes and just like the
remake fireworks light up the sky what
do you guys think about the newest
Aladdin trailer visit tickle your fancy
or grate your cheese let us know in the
comments but first let's find out why
the trailer is receiving mixed reviews
one of the most obvious reasons why
millenials are bashing the live-action
remake is due to Will Smith's portrayal
of the legendary genie reddit users are
going crazy with rage over the casting
but come on guys let's not disobey for
we try it some fans are ticked off by
Marwan Khan's Ari's performance as Jafar
right at user loose Dania gave a
negative review accusing the actor of
sounding board other editors believe
that he won't do the villian justice
yikes now that's harsh we think he did a
pretty good job from what we saw in the
trailer but we'll have to wait to see
the movie from start to finish to judge
his performance although this
live-action remake has received some
backlash many fans are impatiently
waiting for May 24th to roll around what
do you guys think about Jafar and genies
before we wrap up this video we want to
take the time to point out some major
differences between the two movies we
couldn't help but spot these outs while
comparing the trailers first of all
Jafar doesn't transform himself into an
old man to convince Aladdin to enter the
Cave of Wonders Jafar went through great
lengths to protect his identity from
Aladdin in the original film so we were
surprised to see Jafar in his natural
form during the scene does this mean
that Jafar isn't as magical as he was in
the original another thing we couldn't
help but notice is that the new Atlantan
rep zealand ahead of time in the
original movie Aladdin only rubs the
lamp after getting trapped in an
underground cave by Jafar he rubs the
lamp and ends up tricking genie into
getting him out of the predicament for
free but in the remake we see Aladdin
rubbed the lamp as soon as he gets his
hands on it is this a camera trick or
his Disney going off script why would
Aladdin rub the lamp before getting
trapped doesn't sound like something a
diamond in the rough would do to us
there are some notable differences
between the original and the remake but
that's to be expected
for now we're left wondering why Will
Smith's character can go from a blue
genie to a regular looking dude and why
Jasmine isn't primarily showcased in her
classic outfit we want answers Disney so
what do you guys think about the trailer
have you already bought your tickets let
us know in the comment section below
before you go make sure to give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to hit that subscribe button thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]